s'il ya plus de pôles de santé à qu il
n'y a plus de développements possibles
pour le territoire n'est ce pas ça y
compris le cher le cher à part le diable
du sancerrois
sinon même temps le petit hameau du cher
jusqu'à belle vides sont démunis de
soins et donc que ça va appauvrir
complètement le bassin de vie avec ce
qu'il y a de vivre là il ya possibilité
justement de donner aux gens l'envié de
venir sur nos territoires pour faire du
travail télétravail et d'autres
possibilités de travailler à distance
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai toujours quelque part donc en
2000 réunion de la campagne j'ai
toujours prôné une union sacrée autour
de ce pôle de santé de manière cardon
parce que tout le monde tout le monde
forment un groupe puisse faire pression
sur l'état puisque la rsc l'état nous le
territoire ce qu'on souhaite c'est ça
corresponde à ce qu'on a besoin
et puis que ce soit quelque chose la
santé c'est primordial on a on a
quantité de personnes qui voulaient une
fois arrivé à la retraite qui voulaient
venir des personnes qui étaient dans les
grands centres qui voulait retrouver une
tranquillité qui venait dans notre
région parce que c'est une région
agréable et venaient parce qu'on avait
et alors vous voyez vous voyez derrière
on est rendu là radiologie c'est une
remorque